well once a person is confirmed positive
for COBIT 19 a whole new process starts
tracking down anyone they may have come
into contact with 8 news now reporter
Kate Huston shows us how contact tracing
works and why it's so important I'm at
one of the health districts kovat 19
testing sites
I'm told that community testing and
contact tracing go hand in hand and it's
essential to the reopening of Nevada
contact tracers are in charge of
tracking down close contacts of people
who have tested positive for kovat 19
and asking them to self quarantine and
monitor symptoms this could be someone
you live with or spend significant time
with right now the Southern Nevada
Health District has 60 designated
contact tracers on staff its recruited
10 medical volunteers and eight
librarians from north Las Vegas to help
with the labor intensive workload but as
testing becomes more widespread
they'll need even more assistance we're
continuing to enhance our community
testing capabilities the more you test
the more you're going to find which
isn't necessarily a bad thing the Health
District is in the process of applying
to a 96 million dollars statewide grant
from the CDC this will help increase
testing lab capacity and contact tracing
it'll provide about 300 contact tracers
for the state and likely a hundred or
more will be coming down there that
application is due by June 8th
dr. Johnson tells me they don't have a
timeline on when the contact tracers
could arrive but he's hoping within the
coming weeks
he houston 8 news now now another way
that the Health District is alleviating
the workload of contact tracers is
through an app the app sends
notifications to close contacts of
people who have tested positive the
Health District says the app can also be
adapted to use in the future for other
diseases